Kendall Jenner and Bad Bunny All Smiles
courtside at Friday night's Lakers game
it's super enjoyable it's kind of hard
not to have fun doing it yeah check out
the pair having a ball watching the
Golden State Warriors face off La for
game six goodbye happiness nothing
anything complicated and eyewitness
tells ET Bad Bunny was featured on the
Jumbotron and seemed surprised by the
moment
may I be
80s also learned the couple seemed
comfortable together and even greeted
fans as they grabbed some beers I mean
we're normal people we're just like
anyone else I always be my myself I like
to keep my private life pretty private
so I try my best but at the same time I
don't I don't like to let being seen out
in public with someone like affect my
everyday life while Kendall and Bad
Bunny enjoyed a date night Kim
Kardashian and North also hit up the
arena to catch the game I don't know
what's gonna top that and eyewitness
tells ET the cargener sisters weren't
seated near each other but that didn't
stop them from cheering on Chloe's ex
Tristan Thompson with Northeast showing
support in a special way I mean it's
awesome Kendall and bad Bunny's outing
comes months after the duo sparked
dating rumors oh my God just be cool
it's fine and since they've been spotted
getting cozy on several occasions from
horseback riding in April to attending a
Met Gala after party together earlier
this month it's really exciting a source
recently told ET the two are getting
closer and closer every day and they're
getting more smitten with each other as
they spend more time together what kind
of qualities are you looking for in a
relationship
uh I think all is about you know be
honest always be honest
et's also learning Bad Bunny genuinely
makes Kendall happy he's a big romantic
which Kendall finds very attractive and
sweet everything's like so good right
now and I'm very happy so
[Music]
foreign